The author of Hebrews
Proves that the New Testament is a fulfillment of the shadows that the Old Testament give us,
Showing that the Old Testament, the rituals, and all the law of Moses is a shadow
Of the life that we have in Christ Jesus;
But with a difference: the key word in Hebrews is the word BETTER
Because the fulfillment is better than the shadow, amen?
Who wants to live  the shadow? Who wants to dedicate himself to the shadow?
Here on this platform my body is casting a shadow here on the wall
And you can study the shadow and discover many things, one thing that I notice here is that that person has glasses,
You can study, search The shadow and learn many things and there are no lies in the shadow,
But why studying the shadow so much? No  I am not saying that you should not study the old testament, no, no, no
Why search deeply in the shadow when we can see the Life?
Who cast the shadow of the old testament? Paul says: Christ himself and the life  in him, amen?
Do not misunderstand me!, I am not minimizing the importance of the old testament at all,
It is more human beings, very carnal, earthly, it is impossible to understand the spiritual
Without Understand the earthly, which the old testament gives us and reveal to us, impossible!